the great Jay Bilas from the worldwide
leader in sports how are you Jay I am
doing great rich how are you what are
you like on the first day of the
tournament what am I like yeah uh well
after the 25 hour marathon I'm a little
bit of a growling bear hmm is that is is
that the me is that the nickname of
Montana should I uh should I get ready
for that tonight against my alma mater
okay there the Grizzlies don't know that
they're necessarily growling but I
wouldn't worry too much about your alma
mater I think they're a pretty good
shape no it's interesting Jay because it
seems that the tournament selection
committee rewards teams that are on fire
all season long they reward teams that
are thought to be top ten and then
finished top ten and then the teams that
that that build that build and mold and
get ready for tournament time those
teams I guess they don't get rewarded
with top seeds or in the case of
Michigan a location that's
geographically sound for them would you
agree with that assessment
yeah the locations are based upon the
seed so the the when you go down the
seed line so if Michigan was like the
third number three or whatever it was
and the the higher seeds get priority so
yeah you know I'm not crazy about the
way they do that geographically but that
that's just a function of the bracketing
principles they use the selection
I thought left a lot to be desired this
year and I'm not a fan like the
committee the committee is full of great
people but it changes all the time so
every time there's a new new chair it
goes in a different direction and I'm
not a big fan rich of sort of the
committee sending messages I don't think
that's their charge
I think the charge is to take the best
teams after the automatic qualifiers are
in and and I think they made a bunch of
mistakes in that regard you know I don't
look at it we're you know when they say
full body of work and then they complain
that in a non-conference season the team
didn't go on the road and now you're
saying wait a minute if they get enough
road games in their conference season if
you're saying full body of work why
should that matter I think they make a
lot of mistakes but the good news is no
matter how many mistakes they make we
always have a good tournament but you
make seeding mistakes and it affects it
affects the bracket
and we've seen it in past years where
you know Kentucky was an eight and there
was no way they were an eight and they
wound up beating Wichita State so it was
unfair to Wichita State
you could argue it was unfair to
Kentucky after playing number one but
they got paired with the number one that
they were just as good as they were a
four seed that year and they did a lot
of that in this this year's tournament
there are a lot of seeds that were more
off and there were a bunch of teams that
got in where you say they take Arizona
State for example and look Bobby
Hurley's team at a good year but they
did all their work at the beginning of
the year they didn't want a road game
after Christmas and in USC who lost in
the first round of the NIT 2 or 1 in the
first round the energy but but USC they
finished second in their league Arizona
State finished 9th and USC went to the
title game of their tournament and at
Arizona State was out the first round
and you go wait a minute how does that
work that doesn't make any sense
so in terms of under seeding what would
you say here Arizona at 4 where would
you where would you you pegged before we
start moving on actual games being
played oh man there was a bunch of them
but but they're a bunch of but but I'd
say the the ones at the top of the
bracket that really make those the most
impact I would say that Michigan State
is a 3 was was totally miss Edith
Michigan State should have been great
with Xavier on the one line and they
were 29 and 4 and won the big 10
outright and and just because they lost
to Michigan in the in the big 10
tournament shouldn't have disqualified
them when you're looking at teams that
had double digit losses that were
contending for for two seeds and one
seeds that didn't make a whole lot of
sense and I do think Arizona was under
seated as or and you know but overall
you know that they're there within
shouting distance on some of them but
but just and they moved a bunch of teams
up and down the seed line based upon
whether they had another team in their
league that was in the same bracket and
I'm not crazy about that either I think
all these teams play so much and
sometimes a void they might only play a
team in their league once I don't think
you you mess with the the seeding based
upon hey they're gonna play a team in
there that came from their league so
what like like just play Jay Bilas here
the Rich Eisen show okay so who is your
final four J I had I had Villanova
Virginia Michigan and Michigan State in
in my final four now if I were making
those picks now today I would probably
put Arizona in there over Virginia
simply because Virginia lost DeAndre
hunter the next man of the year in the
ACC broke his wrist so he's out the
remainder year obviously the tournament
and that's a big loss for Virginia
that's basically taking a he was their
best NBA prospect and you take that guy
out of the fold he's a redshirt freshman
so he had some real experience that's a
huge loss for Virginia can they overcome
it I think they can but I wouldn't I
wouldn't bet on it and so who do you
have in in the final game and winning it
all then J I had I had Virginia because
of the way they defend but I would I
would obviously rethink that without
hunter and I had Michigan State you know
in Michigan State winning it and it's
funny rich like I you know you try to do
all this bracket analysis when the when
the bracket comes out and factoring in
everything that happened during the
season what you've seen I pick Michigan
State at the beginning of the year and
to win it and it's it's remarkable over
the years and I've been at this a while
now it's remarkable how often what you
think at the beginning of the year want
winds up being a sort of better a better
judgment than what you think at the end
and I don't know how to factor all that
in but but it's amazing how many times
you know you've had a judgment at the
beginning of the year before ball has
been bounced that winds up being more
accurate than your end-of-the-year
predictions so um if it's Arizona
against Michigan do who do you have one
in that one I still like Michigan State
Arizona is really good they don't shoot
it quite as well as Michigan State I
think Michigan State's a little bit
better defensively but Arizona's got
DeAndre and he's the best player in the
tournament and and he's a he's a
transcendent player you don't see guys
like him very often he'll be the first
pick in the draft and he'll be an NBA
all-star be a Hall of Fame caliber
talent and often times in the tournament
you know if the one all else fails and
you're making your pick count the pros
and an ting the team has got
most pros because there hasn't been a
team that's won in the last 20 years
that hasn't had a NBA players on it well
I mean we might as well get to the whole
pro conversation then Jay Bilas here on
the Rich Eisen show so much conversation
as you know on shows like this one and
shows and this show about the
one-and-done and how the NBA needs to
step in and fix what the FBI is
attempting to shine a light on what
would you say is the fix here Jake I
think the fixes the amateurism piece
which the n-c-double-a will not look at
they won't even entertain the idea they
are they are all in on this amateur as a
thing and and I think it's a huge
mistake when you've got billions of
dollars floating around and I'll tell
you this that this one-and-done
conversation is just a red herring
because one and you know if everybody
could go out of high school it would not
change the issues the college basketball
faces because it hasn't changed the
issues of college football faces Reggie
Bush was not a one-and-done and he he
his family took money from an agent that
stuff happens all the time and it's
going to continue to happen because
these players are worth a ton of money
and they're worth way more than a
scholarship so the idea that the
one-and-done is going to be the the
be-all and end-all if they let players
go out of high school we have these
problems back when players could go
right out of high school and and they're
not going to go away and until we allow
players to operate in the same
marketplace that the coaches
administrators do we're not going to you
know we're not going to get anywhere in
the administrators in the answer
double-a not just the folks in
Indianapolis I'm talking about all that
all the member schools the folks that
make the rules you know they like they
like to somehow say that well it's such
a great deal that the players get there
they're leaving school debt-free they
get they get gear and they get look at
all the great travel as if those aren't
business trips and the administrators
don't go on those as well and the
coaches but if it's such a great deal my
think's always been if it's such a great
deal let that deal stand and stand on
its own in the marketplace and we'll be
fine ha ha so would you cap that what
would be paid to players I mean because
no no I would so and the reason the
reason is rich there's no spending
control in any other area there's no cap
on what coaches make there's no cap on
how big athletic departments can be
there's no cap on how much they can
spend on facilities or travel is alike
the only spending control the only wage
ceiling is on players and and that's the
that's the lifeblood of teams is you are
not going to be good unless you have
players and everybody knows and that's
why they want to keep the lid on this
they don't want to have to compete for
talent and the thing I hear all the time
is how complicated this would be and you
know these schools all these schools
that we're talking about have 30,000
25,000 employees and you know if we said
well geez what do we do with all these
employees do we pay the landscaper the
same as the president University do we
pay the best professor the same as the
worst professor like everybody works
hard this is just too complicated we
shouldn't pay anybody let's give them
their expenses and we don't have to
worry about it that that would be silly
and and people would laugh at that the
same way they should laugh at it with
players and these schools they know
exactly who to recruit and they know
exactly - who to put in the game when
they need to win they know exactly who
to pay they just don't want to so they
make up this stuff about oh it's so
complicated you know the the the
volleyball player works just as hard as
a basketball player well you know what I
think the secretaries of some of these
administrators work just as hard as they
do but but we're not paying the
secretary the same as we paid the
commissioners of conference so and
that's not fair it's just not fair so
let's let me use a couple more minutes
here with Jay Bilas extrapolate this out
so zion williamson so would coach kane
and do could be competing with let's
just say whoever's tanking it lent the
Atlanta Hawks the Phoenix Suns right now
but that Duke would have to come up with
more scratch than whatever Williamson
would make as the first overall
selection in the NBA how would that work
well if they wanted to but I think it
would be more more along the lines of
competing with other schools so just as
you would go in for a home visit and
make a pitch and say hey here's what we
can do for you here's what we can offer
look at our facilities look at this
you'd say hey Zion we think you're going
to be a really good player will offer
you X amount of dollars for a two-year
contract to be to be at whatever he's
going to do so to be at Duke and then
Kentucky can say will offer you X plus X
plus 5% or whatever
just like you would with a coach like
we're not saying with coaches geez you
know what if they go to the NBA and
we're not valuing coaches based upon
their value in the NBA because very few
coaches would have any in college would
have any value in the NBA or the NFL
they're valued based on this market the
college sports market so it would barely
be orderly to offer him a contract and
maybe Sian Williamson and his people and
his agent would say you know what we
don't want it we don't want Sian to have
to be locked into a two-year deal we'll
take less money for a one-year deal and
the opportunity for him to go pro and
then you can come back at the end of his
one-year and make an offer if not maybe
he'll transfer and take it off or
somewhere else or maybe he'll go pro it
would really be you know the free market
works remarkably well for the rest of us
so all they'd have to do is offer a
contract when you sign on the dotted
line
you have contract remedies everybody's
got it and if anybody messes with your
player like what they call poaching and
I don't see how you can poach an amateur
student but if it's a professional
enterprise then then if anybody messes
with your your player you've got
contract remedies against them tortious
interference with contract it works it
works very well with the rest of the
free world and the idea that wouldn't
work well for players is patently absurd
really that's what helps to have a legal
degree with a basketball mind Jay Bilas
last one for you so is Condoleezza
Rice's Commission on college basketball
reached out to you to sound these things
out I've talked with a couple members of
the committee privately but they have
not reached out for me to come in there
and testify if you will or appear before
the committee and I'm very optimistic
there are a lot of great people on that
commit there all great people so I'm
optimistic but but cautiously so because
I think the n-c-double-a is already
decided to double down on their
amateurism piece and and that's not even
going to be looked at they'll look at
you know whether players should have
relationships with agents or whether
whether they could have endorsement
deals and I'll say no to that because
they'll say well that would be a
nightmare and recruiting and we don't
want we don't want players we don't want
bidding wars you know I always thought
the bidding war thing was really funny
they don't say bidding war with regard
to anybody else it's just players those
would be bidding wars for coaches it's
just business you know they don't talk
about a bidding war for coaches that's
just business that's the market and and
players have a market too
and in all these schools their
scholarships are worth different amounts
they have a cost associated with them
but they're worth different things and
you get different things at different
benefits being at different places so if
the n-c-double-a thinks hey you know
your opportunity to market yourself and
the tournament is is so great hey if
that's such a great deal let it stand on
its own and if somebody says hey we'll
give you the opportunity to market
yourself and money then we'll see it
we'll see where where the value really
lies and it actually works out better
for the smaller conference teams because
say a place like Wichita State
Wichita State cannot even sniff any of
the recruits that Kansas is getting but
if Wichita State can pay they could pay
more to get for their number one target
as Kansas is fourth best player then
Kansas could play that force but pay
that fourth best player so all of a
sudden these smaller teams could marshal
resources to get better players than
they could otherwise get it would
actually help the smaller conference
teams be more competitive rather than
less Jay I hope you get a chance to get
in front of that committee I would love
to have your ideas out there like that
Jay yeah they won't do that because Mark
Emmert in the room and I don't I don't
think he wants to sit across from me
does he think you're coming for his job
no no I just I just think they don't
want to like one of the things and I say
this respectfully because Mark Emmert a
nice guy but but they don't like you
would think that if their their argument
was so good that they would be able to
justify their positions but they don't
want to make these arguments the only
time Mark Emmert and his brethren make
any arguments is when it's got an NCAA
logo behind it they're talking to their
own people so they'll have a they'll
have what they call an open forum but
they're being asked questions by their
own people so it's basically they're
there they're singing to one another out
of the same gym no they never put
themselves in a position to have to to
deal with the contrary opinion they're
just there they're all when they say
something is just all the same people
that are nodding their heads because
they're all n-c-double-a folks and so
they don't they don't ever put their
arguments out in the marketplace they
just talk to each other
Jay I love our chats thanks for the time
we'll chat again small weekly
always a pleasure rich great being with
your brother right back at you Jay Bilas
at Jay Bilas on Twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays
at noon eastern on audience